(funky music)
♪ Yeah, okay, it's Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪ Sippin' Empathy ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Putting out all of my shit for free ♪
♪ This is Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪ Mike don't make no flip ♪
♪ Take no brick ♪
- Always ends so abruptly.
You know, it always ends so abruptly.
Hello everybody.
I'm sorry I'm five minutes late,
I just had an executive call.
It is April 22nd.
I am Gary Vaynerchuk,
this is Tea with GaryVee.
Desktop numbers ones and twos,
let's get it going.
Please share the URL on
Facebook, Twitter, YouTube,
tag some friends,
let's get some new friends in the mix.
Let's get into the show.
Wow.
Hi Jewel.
- Hi, are you there?
Nice to see you.
- It's great to see you, this is fun.
How you doing?
- I'm really good.
How are you doing?
- I'm really well, thank you for asking.
- Good.
- Family's well?
Everybody's hanging in?
- Yeah, we're in the
mountains in Colorado,
and I'm a natural recluse
so I'm doing good.
- I'm glad, I'm glad.
My team was trying to keep this a secret,
but I saw something so
I knew you were coming,
so I'm super excited that you're here.
- Right on, I appreciate it.
Likewise.
- You have any questions?
- Not particularly.
- Good.
You gonna play a little music?
- Yeah, oh are we on and live?
Sorry.
- We are on and live.
- Very cool.
- Yeah, I've been just thinking
about how are people doing?
When I look at this pandemic,
I really see it as this three-fold thing.
I see the virus is obviously one pilar,
and the economic fallout
which I don't think we've
quite gotten a grip on,
but that's gonna be and then
the mental health fallout,
- It's really happening.
- Suicides tend
to nearly double during recessions
and that's never been during a pandemic
or during isolation.
Suicide hotlines are up 300%.
I have a youth foundation where all we do
is help kids with suicidal ideation.
What have you seen in
like in your comments
and your fans talking about their anxiety?
- That.
I think a lot of people are struggling,
and so I have seen a little
bit of a silver lining.
I've spoken to a couple
of people who are getting
help through this kind of interaction,
through video,
which they thought,
similar to me with meetings,
they thought they needed to be in the room
with their person whoever that may be,
and they've been able to
get the value through this
which makes it feel scalable
which one fan who I've
gotten friendly with
you know now feels that she can
travel because she can do it
on the laptop versus being in the room.
And so you know like everything,
there's always the pros and the cons,
but yes, there is a lot of anxiousness,
and I think to your
point the ramifications
on the economy post this,
there's a lot of people out of jobs slash
consumer behavior will change forever.
You know what don't we know?
You know what don't we know
that is changed forever
in retail, in restaurant, in travel?
I mean you can imagine a world
that even 24 months from now
travel is down 20 to 35 percent you know,
or hotels or conferencing,
so there's just a lot.
There's a lot.
- Yeah, my main concern
is trying to help people.
We're gonna come out of
this one of two ways.
We're gonna be more
resilient, more capable.
We're gonna say, "These are
ideas that no longer serve me,
beliefs and systems and functions."
- That's real.
- "These are ones that
are gonna replace them
because I've used this time
to be really thoughtful,"
or people are gonna become
so anxious and so worried,
which is understandable,
but if we don't understand what to do
with worry and anxiety,
it's gonna escalate into pathologies,
and I can foresee and
world where many people
come out of this more afraid,
more scared, more disempowered.
- They will.
They will for a certain period
of time in certain ways.
I mean look what 9/11
did to a lot of people,
completely changed their frameworks,
their political views, their anxiety,
so yeah, I mean this a real world event.
This will be talked about
hundreds of years after we're gone,
so this is real stuff.
This is real, real, real stuff.
- So I've been working
with kids for 18 years,
the youth foundation
called Inspiring Children,
and I give them a toolkit of
mindfulness in motion tools.
So mindfulness has two
components in my eyes,
meditation, which is one,
and then you have to create exercises.
It's like the gym.
If you go to the gym, you build a muscle.
That's great but unless you
use that muscle during the day,
it's not gonna change your life.
Meditation's the same way.
Meditation actually builds a muscle.
They've learned in eight weeks
it can grow new folds
in your frontal lobes,
and shrink your amygdala
where anxiety lives,
but if you don't put that muscle to work
it isn't gonna change your life.
So the tools that I developed,
I actually developed them
while I was homeless,
but they were recently proven to work
by a neuroscientist
named Dr. Judson Brewer,
to help rewire your brain
thanks to neuroplasticity,
which is just a fancy way of saying
starve old habits and you build new ones.
So the kids and I put the
tools up on a free Web site,
called jewelneverbroken.com.
- Jewelneverbroken.com?
- Yeah, jewelneverbroken.com,
and it's free three-minute exercises
that actually will help rewire you,
and one of the main things I wanted to
cause I know we don't have a ton of time,
but I just wanted to kind of
put this in people's ears,
that there's only two
basic states of being.
There's dilated and
then there's contracted.
Both are important,
but when you do them at the wrong time
it can be really uncomfortable,
so joy, gratitude, curiosity, observation
helps you dilate, relax,
and that's actual neurological,
neurotransmitter and vascular,
everything changes.
Contraction is anxiety, fear,
worry, doubt, anger, etc.
And you can't be in two states at once,
so the best hack that I
ever learned for anxiety
for me when I was homeless,
you know my car I was
living in got stolen,
it was awful.
I was having panic attacks, agoraphobia,
and I learned that if I was heading
into a highly anxious state,
I could feel my whole body constrict,
I just had to profoundly make myself
have a thought or a
feeling the dilated me,
and I always used gratitude.
Your vascular system dilates,
your neurotransmitters change,
it's really profound,
and no matter how little you have
there is something to be grateful for.
So there's an exercise
that kind of helps you
practice that on the Web site,
but I wrote a song called "Grateful"
just 'cause I felt like
that was the medicine that
- I'm a fan of that word.
- helped me and I know
you're big on gratitude.
By the way, what you're doing
with the ALL IN is incredible.
- Thank you.
- That's amazing.
It's been so awesome.
- It's been really fun.
I think I want to enter all those raffles.
- I know, I needing to step up my game.
Like I don't even know what I could offer
that's that cool.
There's such cool packages.
- I'll hit you up after this.
You could do amazing things,
you could have the one.
Can you play a little bit of it?
And then I'm gonna get
to some of the questions before I get off.
- Yep.
- Thanks, Jewel, this is fun.
♪ When everything's wrong ♪
♪ And I can't find my song ♪
♪ When darkness is all I see ♪
♪ There is a remedy ♪
♪ 'Cause it's all the little things ♪
♪ That make the world go round ♪
♪ It's all the little things ♪
♪ That are most powerful ♪
♪ There's no politician ♪
♪ No one's got to die, ♪
♪ No one can take the love from my heart ♪
♪ And sing and a shine
in this heart of mine ♪
♪ Sing and I'm so strong ♪
♪ 'Cause I can always be grateful ♪
- Too good, too good.
You are so amazing.
Jewel, thank you so much for being on.
- Yeah.
- Let's get that Web site
up one more time, Dustin.
Jewel, what's that Web site
one more time for everybody.
- Jewelneverbroken.com,
and I just launched this song, "Grateful,"
if people want to check it out.
- We are gonna check it out.
Jewel, love you, take care of yourself.
We'll talk to you.
- Bye.
- Bye, bye.
- See you, bye.
- Man if I could sing, I'd
be at in whole nother level.
I just listened to that,
I was like, "Fuck man."
Anyway, let's keep it going.
Fun way to start the morning.
Gino.
- Gary.
- What's good, bro?
- Good morning, man, how you doing?
- It's morning, I'm really well.
What can I help you with?
- Just had a question for you man.
So I'm a artist, I was always a artist,
that's kind of how I got into music,
but recently I started to song write
to kind of break in the industry,
and I've had a lot of success,
like multi-platinum,
things are going really well.
- That's awesome, bro.
- Thank you.
But recently you know we decided
to kind of kick off the artist
thing and go full in on that.
I recently dropped a record,
and so I'm kind of shifting my focus
back into being an artist,
but I don't want to loose
the song-writing momentum,
so I guess my question is.
- Both.
- Both, right?
- You have it in you.
- Yeah.
- Like people think
about things in theory,
like there's a theory
that if you're not all in
on one or your other
you can't pull it off,
when that makes no fucking sense.
- Right.
- Like I'm running
the fastest-growing
agency in Madison Avenue
which is hardcore shit, it's competitive,
I'm competing against
multi-billion dollar companies,
and I'm building one of the
most prolific personal brands.
There's so many people
that want to be "GaryVee"
on social media that that's all they do,
yet it's the minority of what I do.
I spend most of my time
being an actual executive.
- Right.
- And launching Empathy Wines,
and helping my dad with WineText,
and you know like.
You've got that in you, you know.
Like if you wake up in the morning,
you feel like you want
to write something, boom.
If you want to go in studio
and keep that song for you, boom.
If you want to give that
song to the baby, boom,
like there is no fucking rules.
- Right, right, yeah.
- It's in your head or
people around you saying,
"Yo, if you don't go all in on one thing,
you're gonna have your ass on two toilets,
and you're not gonna be
able to pull it off."
- Yeah, I think a lot of it is like,
it's no such much a concern
that I can't do both,
'cause I know I can.
- Okay.
- I've been doing it.
I think of a lot of it is just trying
to find the balance 'cause
you know I'm doing like six,
seven sessions a week on the writing tip,
so yeah I don't know.
- I guess
- So do four.
- Right.
- Let's talk about writing.
You know it's one song.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know, so bro you know,
it's not seven songs a week.
- Right.
- You write one fucking banger
that changes your whole life forever.
- Right.
- Right?
- Thanks, yeah.
- So I think you're judging
yourself for no reason.
Do whatever feels right.
You wanna go three straight weeks
on a fucking binge
writing tour, mazel tov.
You wanna go in the fucking
booth for a month, good.
You wanna do one day, one day, one day.
My biggest issue that I'm
trying to change in the world,
is people judging themselves.
Just do what the fuck feels right.
- Yeah, let me ask you,
okay so you're running
so much shit at once,
are there like periods where
you prioritize something,
like all right I gotta
go in on this today.
Like I gotta go
- Yeah, yeah.
Like today I have to do a
call with my London office
to look at their finances,
so Tea with GaryVee is
not 9 to 11, it's 9 to 10.
- Right.
- I prioritized the London office.
- Yeah.
- I was five minutes late for this.
I prioritized my epic
call with the Tracer team,
tracer.tech is you're
looking at some software
to help you with your social
if you're a big company,
so you know like I prioritize
every fucking second,
but I don't make some master
plan and and write it on paper
and think that this is
gonna be my next 400 days.
- Yeah.
- Everyone had a five-year
plan until some lady
ate a bat in China and fucked it all up.
- Right.
- What happened to your
fucking five-year plans
now everybody?
What happened to your
fucking five-year plan now?
Some lady ate a bat in China
and fucked your shit up.
On some real shit.
That would be like a joke
that I would make a year ago
to talk about don't make five-year plans.
- Yeah.
- Yeah prioritize daily,
not yearly, not in the macro,
not on a fucking Excel sheet,
not on my fucking pad.
I live it.
- Right, I think that's been the blessing,
if there is that,
of this whole thing is like I've been
if I don't feel like doing it today,
if I wake up and I'm like,
eh I'm not inspired, I don't force it.
I do something else that you know.
- Bingo, get back to your audience, write.
Yeah don't force,
but don't lay in bed and
just dwell on everything.
Do something.
(background noise drowns out conversation)
- Gotcha.
- Word.
- All right my man, stay well.
- Sure, all right.
- Let's go, let's go, let's go Gino.
In the building, I like him.
Joel, how are you?
- Great, how are you doing?
- I'm quite well.
- Good.
- It's great to see you.
- Yeah, good to see you.
In enjoyed reading a little
bit of your biography
about how as a child you
became an entrepreneur.
I had the same experience.
I was 11 when I started my first business.
- I love that.
What were you doing?
- I was delivering fresh
vegetables that I'd grown
around the neighborhood.
I hired my little brother to take 'em
around the neighborhood in
a red Radio Flyer wagon.
- I love that, I love that.
How you been hanging in?
- Pretty well, all things considered.
I mean the airline industry's a tough one.
I'm in a bunch of other
businesses as well,
but the airline business
is particularly hard hit.
Airlines, hotels, cruise ships
I think are the three toughest.
- I think that's right.
I think that's right.
What can I help you with?
- Just eager to talk with you
about whatever you want to talk about.
- You know I'm kind of in a place
where I think there's an
enormous amount of opportunity.
You know I think that right now everyone's
gotta kind of settle into their realities,
you know like they have
to cross their t's and dot their i's,
but for me all I want to talk about
is offense and optimism.
- That's such a great message.
I think it's gonna reshuffle the deck.
I think the people that
are the most creative,
have the most ingenuity, are
best grounded in principles,
and I've just written this book
call "The Entrepreneurial Leader,"
which I think is gonna
be required of everyone
is to be more entrepreneurial.
No more presiders, no more
managers, no more administrators,
it's really gonna require
leaders to be entrepreneurial.
- And that goes in my mind as creative.
You've gotta just rethink.
You know the status quo
is extremely dangerous
when innovation is required,
and this moment requires
enormous innovation,
rethinking and most of all humility.
Many are gonna struggle
going back into the world
and not having the same amount of money,
the same amount of status,
the same amount of "cush" opportunity.
You know organizations
that go from 800 to 437
are gonna require all 437 to "work,"
where at 800 they had the fat
to get away with being in meetings.
- Yep, yep.
I think that's exactly right.
I think it's gonna require
a lot of things of people.
One of the things that I think leaders
are gonna have to do better
is communicate more directly
bad news as well as good news
before, during and after the fact.
I actually think it's gonna
require people to be kinder.
- I think that's right.
- I know people don't think about that,
but I think there are a lot
of people who are vulnerable,
and I think a word of kindness,
you know dropping somebody a note,
giving them a call,
checking up on them
making sure they're okay,
and I think volunteering.
I've given blood a couple of times,
or I'm scheduled to give
blood another time here,
and I think you kind of lose
yourself in helping others.
I think that's a good way
to get through these kinds of crises.
- I think that's right my friend.
I really appreciate you being on.
- Yeah, my pleasure.
- Yeah, have a great, great day Joel.
- All right, take care.
- All right
- [Both] Bye now.
- Thanks, Mia.
Let's keep it going.
- What's going on Gary? How you doing?
- It's good, Will.
I'm doing quite well,
appreciate you being on.
- Great being with you, brother.
I have a question specific
to my situation now,
but it makes sense to give
you a bit of a back story.
So I'm 38.
I'm from Toronto, Canada.
I had a just shy of a
10-years run at finance.
I built up a career in finance,
I guess did fairly well.
I could have swore I was happy,
making good money, low stress,
and then about two years ago
I sort of questioned everything.
You know it sort of just
hit me like a ton of bricks,
like what am I doing?
What makes me happy?
Long story short, I decided to quit.
My passion is audio engineering,
It's something I've always wanted to do,
mixing records, working in the studio,
so I pulled the trigger.
I did it not knowing
how it was gonna pan out
because I had no preparation.
I didn't have any friends in the industry.
I had no basis to go on.
I was really on my own on this one,
like nobody in my circle
that really understood my situation.
It was sort of like everybody I knew.
- It's the easiest
situation to understand.
You decided to choose
happiness over being content,
safe and having some money.
- Right.
I mean my wife thought
I was crazy at first.
My friends thought I was crazy.
- You weren't happy.
Will, I think it's
crazy that 98% of people
that watch this don't do that shit.
- I think so, too.
- I think you were awake.
- But the crazy thing
(microphone cuts out)
that I was actually.
- I'm sorry, go ahead.
- I could've swore I was happy.
I mean it's almost like it
- You were happy in the conscious,
but in the subconscious you weren't.
- Right, right.
- You were happy in the practical.
You were happy in what
you have been taught
as a 38-year-old is winning.
You were happy in the fake.
- Right, right, right.
- You know weren't happy.
You know at 34 on a nap,
or 32 on driving to work,
or 37 during a shower,
that that quick thought
passed through your head.
- Oh, for sure.
- Jumping at 38 means
that you've been building
since 28 to that moment.
- Maybe.
- Definitely.
I'm telling you little moments,
not like every day at 28.
At 28 you're like yeah, I
got that money you know,
but I promise you it was chipping away.
- For sure.
So I did it,
now maybe we can get into
maybe a strategic play
into where I'm at now.
- Sure.
- It's crazy because I'm passionate
about what I'm doing now,
but I mean it just leads me to wonder
how many people are actually
in that state that I was in.
- Everybody.
- And I think I'm almost as passionate
about helping people maybe realize that,
maybe you know I want to put my
- Will, you have a lot
of legs to stand on.
- Right, right.
- You did it.
You know one of the reasons I love being
a known entrepreneur
in this game right now
is 'cause I actually did it,
and a lot of the known entrepreneurs
are just talking about
being entrepreneurs,
so you know they're making their money
selling people on how to make money,
not they've never actually made some.
So the fact that you
had the balls to do it
and the strength and the
inner strength to do it,
is gonna be massively inspirational.
I would argue that you need to be careful
that you're not going down that path
because you think there's more money in it
than the audio engineering thing,
so you've gotta balance that.
And you gotta ask yourself,
"Am I looking to do that
because there's dollars
in selling people to do that,
or is that actually my passion?"
Or is it because the
audio engineering thing
doesn't have the finances
in the first five years
that I may have been accustomed to.
That's a real next challenge
for you in your own dome.
- For sure.
Okay, so maybe we can into
maybe a strategic place
to where I'm at now.
So basically when I quit,
I'd didn't know how
this was gonna pan out.
Like I said I didn't have any
connections in the industry.
I've sort of been building
myself over the last year
to really get going on my
craft and build my chops.
I think early on I started
the whole promotion thing,
like I set up a Web site,
and it didn't take me very long
to figure out like oh,
shit this is an art form,
like this is gonna take me a bit of time
to really you know master,
and I think I'm sort of getting there.
It's been a year and a half now,
and I think I'm ready to start promoting
and start like I'm
building up a portfolio.
I've got some clients now,
it's definitely kind of lining up,
but I think up until now I haven't done
the whole social media thing
just because I didn't
want to do I prematurely.
I didn't want to sell
something and not deliver.
So what's the strategic play?
I mean besides free content,
I mean there's so many
people that are on it.
- Yeah, but that's actually the game.
You know there's a lot of people
that are audio engineers, too.
There's a lot of people that went
into the finance industry, too.
The supply and demand of
content is not the issue.
The ability to deliver value
to somebody on other side is the issue.
- So I guess I've sort of been hesitant
because I mean like I said,
it is an art form.
It takes some.
- But you could've documented the journey
of becoming there.
Like you could have
been a huge inspiration.
I don't know how long
you've been watching me,
but the document over
creating is a big thing.
I would argue that your journey
in that first 18 months of
going from zero and quitting
to becoming an audio engineer
was some of the best content
you could have ever put out.
You know expertise
audio-engineering content
could more commoditized
than being 38 and jumping into
or 36 or whatever the math was
and jumping into your passion,
so you know there's always opportunities
to bring value as a content creator
for everybody who's watching
if they stay in their truth,
and they play out the snowflake game
which is like we're all unique.
What I'm the best in the
world at is being 100% me,
and I think you will be the
100% you and tell your stories
and showing the crappy audio
work versus the good work.
Like I think there's power in that,
and then people become aware of you
and awareness is branding
which leads to buying.
We don't buy Coca-Cola or
Nike because they sold us,
we just know it and we buy it,
and then we figure out if we like it.
- Right, right, right.
Okay.
No I appreciate that Gary.
- You gotta put out content, bro.
Put out the content.
Just start talking.
- All right, bro, appreciate
it, thanks for everything.
- I'm glad you picked that up.
I could tell when you picked that up.
Thank you.
Take care.
- Bye bye.
- Who's coming in?
He's poised, but you know who knows?
No one knows.
Crystal Maze looks good.
Sandra Bright, thank you for being here.
Samantha Waters, love it.
Thank you for being here.
Let's keep it going.
- Hey, Gary.
- Hey, Karen.
- Carin, actually.
- Carin, sorry.
- Yes.
No you're fine.
Couple of questions.
Bear with me, I'm a little bit nervous.
Big fan of yours.
I listen to you all
the time, all the time.
- Thank you.
- I'm actually looking
for advice or strategies
on getting away from
codependency in business.
- Okay.
- So I've restarted my life
completely about a year ago.
I left my first career, and
I'm chasing my desires now,
working in a luxury real estate market,
and I don't know a lot real estate,
so I joined a team,
and I've met some amazing people
that were helping guide me through,
but I kind of went off on my own,
although I don't have
that confidence any more
so I find myself really
trying rely on other people
in order to get where I need to be.
- That's a mistake.
- Yeah, I know, right.
- You know like I think
what you need to do
is realize it's okay that
you don't know anything.
You're just starting.
- Right.
- You need to make this
the learning process
not the dependency process.
Do you not enjoy the fact that
they have leverage on you?
Do you not enjoy the fact
that you have self-doubt?
Like you're gonna learn it.
- Yeah, it's a self-doubt thing.
- But what are you supposed to
fucking know it immediately?
- No, right.
Well I want to be able to
have educated conversation
'cause these are individuals
it's not like buying a brand new home,
and you have to explain something.
This is a secondary market,
so people who are generally
looking for luxury
are a lot more advanced
in their knowledge.
- Yeah but people buy from people, Carin.
- Right, yeah.
- And as somebody who spends a lot of time
with you know individuals
who you know buy homes
in secondary markets,
it's like they oftentimes
know what they want
more than what the real
estate agent even after 20,
you know what I'm even talking about?
Like the real estate agent
is really just a trust game,
and do they like them.
And the education on the
data is here are the comps
of what the home's sold for.
You know like people that are
in affording a second home
oftentimes are in a place where
they've made good decisions.
They've either made really good decisions
and they really know what the
fuck they're talking about
or they're complete hucksters
and they're about the lose everything
at some point in the next 10 years,
and they actually don't
give a fuck about anything
but looking cool and doing their thing,
so I would argue with you
that secondary home real estate macro DNA
is actually even more about people skills.
I've watched my sister
become highly more educated
over the last two years in
her real estate journey,
and she started at zero
and was concerned about it.
I think you're making a
mountain out of a molehill.
- Okay, okay.
Well so this kind of leads
in to my other thing,
what you were saying about
it's more of a people skill.
I've actually had a couple of individuals
in this small town reach out to me
that me to do promotional
brand ambassador.
They've presented some
opportunities for that,
and I'm fearful to stretch myself too thin
because I'm wanting to
pursue this luxury market
but then I have a garage who's
wanting to get me out there
and do some promoting for
them to get more business,
and then I have a CBD company.
- What does that mean promoting?
Because you have a big following?
- No, I don't, that's what wild to me.
- They think you "look" the part?
- I'm assuming.
- Yeah.
- I mean look, that's up to you.
That's just comes down to
are the economics interesting
for you right now in the short term.
What I would tell you is
you need to be careful
'cause you don't want
to dilute your brand,
and when I hear a CBD
company and a garage,
like you need to decide if
you want to be model life
or if you want to be real estate agent.
By the way you can do both.
It all just depends on
do you feel good about the association?
- Okay.
- You know every time you're
putting yourself there,
like you're associated
and so you need to very.
- My image.
- Yes, your image for sure.
You know number two,
you need to make sure you
believe in the business.
What if god forbid the
business is bullshit and
- I'm associated with it.
- You're associated and get dragged down.
Now on the flip side,
I never judge people's short-term
financial needs, right?
So it's always a friction point,
like is that $5,000 more important
than the long-term brand association,
because the real estate
thing will be patience
plus I'm sure no dope,
you realize that second-home buying
may be slowing down a little
bit here for a little while.
- Yeah, definitely, definitely.
- So these are all the navigations,
but you get to make those decisions.
Just go into make those
decisions with eyes wide open.
- So do you have a suggestion
on finding appropriate
mentors in this situation
because this is new to me.
I came from the medical field,
where people were telling me do this,
do this, do this and we'll pay you.
Now I'm in a position where I kind of get
to figure it out myself,
and I don't know how.
- Mentors tend to be bad
because mentors 85% of the time
give advice that worked for them.
- Okay.
- And so A,
be careful of that because mentors
like to give the blueprint that they took,
and so I think what you need to do
is just consume information.
But you also just have to
make decisions and taste it.
I promise you this,
no you know brand deal with something
is gonna forever kill your brand.
- Right.
- Don't let what I said earlier scare you.
I just want you to be thoughtful
because once you go down that rabbit hole,
you could be doing 27 deals later,
and now your brand's diluted,
and then the friction of transitioning
may be a little bit more difficult.
Or just might get caught
up in the hamster wheel
of the "eaiser money."
- And that's what I'm trying to avoid.
I don't want to just become
another you know promo model
for just anything at this point.
- I completely understand.
- I want to have it all laid out,
especially before my launching.
- But, but, but,
you can do both, you know.
And you can evolve.
You know J.Lo, Tyra Banks, you know.
They start in one place,
J.Lo's a dancer on "In Living Color,"
now she's an entrepreneurial global icon.
- Right, absolutely.
- So you're young enough
to pull it all off,
so what I would say is be
thoughtful but don't be fearful.
- Okay.
- Got it?
- Got it.
Thank you, Gary.
- Okay, bye Carin.
All right, let's keep it going.
Vin, what's good?
- Gary, what's up man?
- I'm super well brother.
- So I'll jump right into it.
I'm the kind of person who likes to have
like a couple of different
projects going at once,
so I definitely want to ask you about one
and then if you have like
30 seconds at the end
for the other one that would be awesome.
If not, no worries.
Quick back story.
It's a little out of left field,
but I run an online community for people
that are on what's called
a low oxalate diet.
It's not a diet in the weight loss sense,
it's more out of medical necessity,
so you'd follow it if you had certain type
of kidney stone or kidney issues,
some people who Crohn's disease
and some other GI issues,
and a few other health conditions.
So in my Facebook group,
I've just been like answering questions
and creating resources for
people for a couple of years.
I do want to start monetizing,
but I just don't want
to be a dick about it.
I'm trying to like put the pieces
to a revenue model together and
- I've got something for you, Vin.
- Okay.
- A, you're hair's fucking amazing.
- Thank you, bro.
- B, I think it's access.
- Okay.
- What I mean by that is
you wanna sell information,
you know that selling information
eight out of 10 times
is quite douchey online,
if you layer access and do what
I'm doing with you right now
for two hours a week for
anybody that buys the program,
I think you can amortize out the concern
that you're just selling information
that they could in theory find
but you've curated it for them.
Add more value to it.
All of a sudden it goes from a $17 book
to a $200 a month thing
because they're getting eight hours of you
doing q and a with the group.
I think access is the layer
that makes it much more palpable.
- Okay.
So the thing is I think like the basics
are like there's a lot of
crappy information out there,
so like what I'm doing is kind
of like sorting through it
and like putting all
the good stuff together,
and then I feel like
if people wanted access
they could get most of the information
that they need up front.
- Access is to you.
- Right.
- Spending time with you.
- Right, that's what I'm saying.
So I think they would spend
an hour or two with me,
like one or two sessions maybe,
and then that would be like enough,
and then after that what most
people want is just recipes.
- No, I think recipes are findable.
They can go on Google, too.
They're gonna drop off eventually.
- That's the thing.
They can't find any for this diet
because there's nothing out there.
There's a little bit out there,
but it's very inaccurate
and it's all disorganized.
- Listen, listen.
You're more than welcome to
go content-only subscription.
Those things tend to peter out.
Layering not individual people, bro,
two hours a week period for all 800 people
that are in the program.
- Okay.
- Got it?
- Yeah.
- I'm not talking about 54
people getting two hours each.
I'm talking give me two hours a week
on top of what your plan is
when everybody comes into the room
and you bring people
in like I'm doing here,
and I promise you you'll build
a substantially bigger business.
- Okay, cool.
So I started a podcast too,
having like some scientists come on,
people that do research.
I'm gonna try and get a couple of MD's,
and then I'm also thinking
about having chefs on.
I already did one with one chef
where she brought some of her recipes,
and then we kind of modified
them like to this diet.
What do you think about that?
And like other kinds of
people to have on the podcast.
- Yeah.
- Just keep doing that?
- Yes.
- Cool.
- What's the name of your podcast?
People want to know.
- It's called Low Oxalate Kitchen.
- Low Oxalate Kitchen.
- Yeah, so I just started it.
I just recorded the first three episodes.
I'm gonna upload the first
one like this week probably.
- ASAP, bro.
- ASAP, yeah, it's coming.
It's coming.
All right, so then one other
question completely unrelated.
You remember that coin
that Ryan Holiday gave you,
the one that said Memento Mori.
- Yeah.
- So I have one of the other ones he made
that says, "The obstacle is the way,"
but when my girlfriend saw that I had it
it was like sort of
during like a little bit
of a rough patch she was going through.
She's had some struggles,
been through some shit,
so I explained to her what it was,
and she was like, "Oh shit,
well like I want one."
She wanted one with more
of like a self-love,
mindfulness, comforting kind of vibe,
and she's a meditation
teacher so she was like,
"Oh, people could probably
mediate with it too."
So long story short we
ended up making some,
and I want to start
like reaching out people
on Instagram or wherever,
really like start sending out DM's,
but I'm not sure like which
people to like to target,
and like what exactly to say.
I'd like to get them to
be into it, you know.
- Target people with
something contextual to them.
Tell them that you admire them,
and you want to send it to them,
and recognize one out of every 87 people
that DM you will take it.
- And then what if I just send it,
like should I like ask
them to post about it
or just send it and forget
it whatever they do?
- The second you ask them to
post about it you've lost.
- Right.
So just send it and then that's it.
All right.
- So one out of 87 will reply,
one out of every nine will
actually post it in their feed,
two out of every nine will
post it in their story
and that's your business.
Their awareness is worth way
more than your fucking coin.
- Right.
- Like me posting something
in my fucking main feed,
my dad fucking picked up
25,000 followers last night.
- You know what I mean?
Like that's worth,
you know "worth,"
in ad money if you spent it on Instagram
to get the same thing to happen,
is worth hundreds of thousands of dollars.
I don't want your fucking coin.
- Yeah.
- So you have to be empathetic.
You know like people are always like,
"Whoa, they don't fucking post."
I'm like, "They don't
want your fucking $8 T.
They don't want your $9 hat.
They don't want your fucking coin."
But if you write something contextual,
and if hits them,
you've got something
a little more soulful,
you might be able to convert some stuff
and that's one way to market
which is everyone wants
their marketing for free,
or you can offer to pay,
or you can run ads.
There's a million different
things you can do,
but you can't be mad at
the fucking influencer
to not post it when their value of it
is so much greater than the
free fucking thing they gave it.
It's like that guy yesterday
on the show was like
"Hey I'm gonna give you two things,
and then can you give me something."
Hey, did you know the Roman
numeral of fucking five was a V.
Yes I did.
Hey, some other horse shit.
And then he's like,
"Now can you record something I can put
on the front of my podcast,
which will help me fucking build my show."
That was a fucking joke.
I did it 'cause I'm a good dude,
but that wasn't like an
epic fucking exchange.
That was me fucking doing charity.
- Right.
All right, cool.
Thank you brother, appreciate it.
- Take care my man.
- Yep.
- Really enjoying Tea
with GaryVee this morning.
Just always enjoying
this show for everybody.
Real quick, Dustin on the back end,
pop in and say hello.
They always love you.
- Dustin, can you get the
name of our Facebook group?
I think everybody on Tea with GaryVee
should join that on Facebook,
like so can you talk to the team.
I mean is that the First in Line group?
Like is that closed maybe?
I mean can you talk to
the team on the back end.
- First in Line is closed, I know that.
- Is there another Facebook group?
I'm like all confused.
- I mean it appears the Gary page,
and there's the GaryVee video experience,
but it's mainly just
- I don't have an open group?
- I'm not sure.
- I'm a little confused.
Can you get up with the team?
Let's keep moving.
- All right, yep.
- Gary, what's going on brother?
- What's up Jimmy?
- Not much, man.
Just super grateful for
everything that you do.
My question basically is that
I play and coach baseball
so the back end of that is
played all through college
my whole life, everything.
Had a really successful college career,
was All American, All
Conference, the whole nine,
but then I figured I might was well do
what I should do, right,
and I went and worked a corporate job,
fucking crushed it but
was massively unfulfilled,
so I said, "Fuck that."
Sold my car,
took a one-way flight to Southeast Asia,
and just traveled for a while.
Then I came back and was
like I miss the game.
Started coaching, started training,
and within a matter of months
signed a professional
contract to go to France.
- Good for you.
- And then with all that,
basically coronavirus happened.
My flight was supposed
to be two weeks ago,
so now I'm just kind of
trying to figure it out,
but in the meantime during COVID,
I've built a pretty decent
but really targeted
audience around baseball,
over 22,000 followers on TikTok,
all thanks to you 'cause
you've been screaming out
the fucking top of the mountaintops.
- I fucking yell it.
- Yeah, you've been yelling bro,
so anything else that you say,
anything you're fucking yelling,
I'm gonna do it.
ALL IN Challenge bought so
I can (microphone drops out)
- Thank you.
- But my question is.
- Which raffles did you buy in to?
- I bought into yours,
and I bought into Michael Rubin's.
- Yeah, Rubin's is nuts.
- I mean they're both just
like ridiculous value.
Are you fucking kidding me, bro?
- Bro, you might want to buy
at least one ticket for
$10 on the Cuban one.
You could literally be in an NBA game.
- Gnarly.
I just got tenacious defense though.
The jumper is not there, it's not there.
- They're just gonna let
you in at the last minute
of the game and everybody's gonna hug you
and they're gonna pull you back out so.
- I'd love that,
but my question is now
that I've kind of built
this targeted audience,
I'm struggling with what do I do next?
Is it too late to get in the podcast game?
YouTube? Twitch?
- Yes, yes, yes.
Like I'm on TikTok live right now,
and I've been (microphone drops out)
and they're like,
"Hey, you need to make Twitch,"
so I've done that in the last week
and built that over 100 followers,
got subs going and stuff on that.
I've just been listening to the audience.
- All in.
- Jimmy, all of it.
- Yes, the answer is yes, right?
- The answer is yes.
The answer is you're young man.
It's always the right time to jump in.
You didn't miss YouTube,
you didn't miss TikTok.
I've been yelling about
TikTok for four years,
Music League then TikTok.
Like you didn't miss Instagram.
It gets harder to get big bases.
TikTok's the only place you
can go to 22K like that,
only place.
- Absolutely.
- But the reality is going nice and slow
on Twitch a hundred at a time
or on YouTube a hundred at a time,
is good too because don't forget.
It's not about how many
subscribers you have,
it's the right subscriber.
- Absolutely.
- Like one executive at
the MLB network sees you,
and the next thing you know
you're signing a $800,000
contract to be on TV.
- 100%.
- Or a high network father
who thinks his three boys
are the next coming of the Alous you know.
It's not how many subscribers you have,
it's which subscribers you have.
- Yeah, true fans, absolutely.
- Not only true fans,
the one person that can change your life
by reaching out.
You're a good-looking dude.
Somebody might just reach out there
and be like "I want you on TV."
- Appreciate that.
- You're welcome, bro.
- And if you have time
for one more question.
- Real fast.
- I understand that it
definitely is the long game,
but how would you
recommend about going about
potentially getting brand deals on TikTok.
- Slowly, slowly.
- Especially with baseball being a super
(microphone drops out)
- Not yet.
I get it, you probably
have a need for money
and different things of that nature,
but I promise you have to.
I'd rather you sell that
Koby and Jordan thing
on fucking ebay right like if you have to.
- Not that.
- I understand, I understand,
but listen to me.
Sell those fucking candles.
Sell your hoodie.
Do not go for brand deals.
Keep building to the audience
so that you have more leverage.
People go in for the brand deal too early.
It fucks them up and
changes the relationship.
Their energy goes to brand deals
instead of making great content,
and they get fucking killed.
- Gotcha.
All right, thank you so much.
Like I said,
super grateful for everything that you do.
Take care.
- Take care of yourself.
All right, let's keep this going.
You knew I was gonna mention
that Jordan thing Ryan.
I know you knew.
Benjamin, what's good?
You're audio's not up.
Somebody just wrote,
"TikTok is young
audience," email recipient.
It's young.
It's gotten ridiculously older
in the last three months,
and it will continue to get older
just like every platform.
Facebook was only college kids.
To remind you, now it's only grandmas.
Talk to me Benjamin.
Still audio.
- Ben, try reloading the
page and then coming back in.
- First in Line group is closed.
TikTok looks so much older now.
It is.
It already is.
TikTok is growing faster than Insta.
Chris B., what's good?
Anthony Davis, what's good?
Steven Richards, what's good?
Martin Joe, Gabriel Costa.
Let's go to the next one Dustin if we can.
Oh, now we got Benjamin.
Benjamin?
- Hey Gary, sorry about that.
- No worries, brother.
- Hey man, so I feel
really late to the game
as far as all of this
social media stuff goes.
- Early, early in the game Benjamin.
- Really?
- I mean it, bro, I mean it.
I'm sorry to cut right in.
- No, I appreciate that.
- You're just not.
- Um, okay.
- Like 'cause it's not.
I don't know what else to fucking say,
you know like Charli D'Amelio
you know explodes since August
and is like one of the most
famous people in the world
kind of in the U.S. right now,
and she started her TikTok
account in like fucking July.
- That's good to hear.
- I mean you could start
a LinkedIn account right.
What do you do?
- I'm a trumpet player.
I'm a professional musician so.
- Bro, you have to get
on TikTok yesterday.
I need you to do me a favor.
That's huge, I'm telling you right now.
My daughter and her friends
think dentists are cool,
I'm being dead serious.
My daughter who's 10 hit
me up six months ago,
she's like, "Dad, you need to be friends
with this dentist on TikTok."
Dentist.
- Okay.
- Have you looked at TikTok yet?
- Yeah, I've like browsed it
for like 10, 15 minutes before.
- Benjamin, we're gonna
change your life right now.
I'm not even kidding,
I'm not even kidding.
I want you to spend five to
10 hours consuming TikTok.
I need you to look at
everything, everything.
What that will do is
get you into the mindset
of what's working on there.
You'll see things you can do.
You'll see things you can't do.
I can't dance.
I can't do the pop and
top like fucking shit,
so I don't dance,
but I can do other things.
I'm telling you right now,
five to 10 hours.
Start your TikTok,
make three TikToks a day.
Three.
We're in quarantine.
The fucking (blowing like horn),
like do other things,
jump on trends, use up the music,
you are going to be blown away.
You watched the last
person doing baseball shit.
I'm telling you, I'm telling you.
TikTok, I'm telling you.
- And is it the type of thing
where I really just do what matters to me?
- Yes.
- or kind try to follow the trend?
- A little bit of both?
- Both.
Yes, if you see something
that feels natural right?
So I'll show you my latest TikTok,
very natural to me.
Ready? Here we go.
♪ So you bagged him ♪
♪ I am savage ♪
- Ready, let me start it over
'cause everybody needs to see it.
♪ So you bagged him ♪
♪ I am savage ♪
♪ Classy, bougie, ratchet ♪
♪ Sassy, moody, nasty ♪
♪ You're acting stupid ♪
♪ What's happening? ♪
♪ I am savage ♪
- Yeah, no booty shaking. I see that.
- No booty shaking, right,
and you know 600,000 views
later 'cause it's on trend
to a Meg The Stallion song
that we could post edit with what I have,
and I'm telling you,
I'm telling you right now,
I think a trumpet player is
like in the perfect pocket,
and not a 15-year-old trumpet player,
you, you, I'm telling you right now
it will work.
- Is TikTok something
that monetizes over time
because I really don't understand.
I see how YouTube does it with ads.
- Yeah but you know what
else modifies over time?
When a fucking dad
fucking DMs you on TikTok
and says, "I need to have
you for my Bar Mitzvah
'cause every fucking 13-year-old
in the world wants you,
and now you're making
$40,000 like a fucking rapper
at a Bar Mitzvah.
- That's deep, I like that.
- It's smart.
- And I mean for me it's
really not about the money,
but I need freedom and comfort you know.
- I respect the shit out of it bro.
- I love making music and playing,
so I'm trying to find ways.
- You're going to make
$10,000 a Bar Mitzvah.
You're gonna literally in 18 months
if you listen to me and
go completely on how I am,
you're going to literally make a video
that's gonna go viral
that I made $10,000 now at a Bar Mitzvah,
and I'm gonna take this
video clip in 18 months,
on whatever to TikTok or Instagram is,
and do my split screen recall
where I fucking gave you the blueprint
and changed your fucking life.
I'm a 100% positive.
- Man, thank you.
- 10 hours of consumption today.
Hang up, all day.
I don't want to fucking hear from you.
Read it all, read it all.
Watch it all.
Get some friends down.
Learn it cold.
Learn it cold and then make
a fucking trumpet TikTok tonight.
- Okay.
- I will.
- I mean it, I promise you.
- I mean is it important to integrate
with the other platforms?
I mean I've done nothing.
- I have no YouTube.
- TikTok.
TikTok.
- Focus on that.
- Start there.
- It's the place where I
think you will explode.
It's also the place where
I think you will monetize.
I genuinely think you're
fucking playing Bar Mitzvahs.
- I've played a couple of Bar Mitzvahs,
but not for 10 grand, though.
- How much do you get paid?
- I mean usually about $300
to $400 for a good gig.
That's normal.
- 10K.
- Wow, okay.
- Get a million followers on TikTok,
and watch that first DM come through.
I promise.
- And it's gonna open up
educational opportunities as well
'cause I'd like to teach
so I mean I want people
to contact me for the information I have.
- TikTok.
- Yeah, thank you.
- 10 hours in the there.
First of all you're gonna enjoy it
'cause it's still a
fun, happy, silly place
so it's just it's just going to be nice.
Better than the shit you
see in the other platforms.
And two, you're gonna make something,
you're fucking make something
and it's gonna fucking suck,
or you're a natural and it's gonna rock.
I don't know,
but you gotta fucking start going.
- But it doesn't have
to be all really geared
towards my musical pursuits, right?
I can do eclectic stuff as well
or is music better?
- No, no mix it all,
but I do think you could be
the trumpet guy of TikTok.
I do.
- Okay.
That's deep.
- If you fucking play
the trumpet of the songs
that are trending on TikTok,
you will win.
You show a little personality,
you do a little stuff,
like you will win, bro.
- I appreciate this, Gary.
Thank you.
- Good luck.
- Brian I am telling you right now,
if I was born in this country
I would be running for president.
I'd fucking win, just so there's no.
Yes, Dustin.
- I just wanted to say
that was really smart,
the whole play the trending songs,
like I see that all the time.
- It's gonna fucking work,
and the monetization,
like people can make pennies on YouTube,
but if they're smart and their business
like I just old him win
every 13-year-old's heart,
you'll be doing Bar
Mitzvahs and Sweet 16s,
till you'll be making a million a year
if he's the trumpet guy of TikTok.
- Yeah, like I remember
when you said on Joe Rogan.
Like Joe Rogan was like saying how,
"I'm not making money off Instagram,"
but then you're saying,
"No, you're making money
off doing your standup,
and all this."
Like it's the other things
that people aren't thinking about.
- People are transactional, I'm brand.
Everyone out here thinks
they're a marketer.
They're a fucking sales person.
I'm a marketer.
Get out of here.
Let's keep it going.
- Hi Gary.
- How are you my friend?
How do you pronounce your name?
- It's Joey.
- It is Joey.
I like the way it's spelled.
Love that.
How are you Jowy?
- Good.
First of all I want to
thank you for being you
and everything you do,
and I wanted to tell you a
little bit about my past.
It's like I studied
accounting and finance,
and growing up I didn't have a dream,
or I didn't know what I
wanted to do with my life.
Basically I struggled
finding a purpose for myself.
So I just want to become an actor
after finishing up accounting and finance,
and so my question
is how do I pursue my dream to be an actor
and like without having
anyone like to back me up?
And also how do I set my priorities?
For example, like I
have debts for old stuff
from studying, right?
Like coming out of school,
I'm at a place where I can't afford
to take courses
to help me grow acting wise,
(speakers talking over each other)
- Go ahead, go ahead.
Keep going.
- No, I was gonna say since I've started
thinking about acting,
it's the law of attraction.
It's like what you think comes your way,
and it's been happening,
like I've been meeting the right people
with the right connections and so on,
but it's just like the
reality keeps pulling into it.
It's like I came to the
realization like I need money.
- Of course you need money.
- Do you have debt?
- I need to be able
- to sustain myself first to be able.
- Yep.
- Where do you live?
- Excuse me?
- I live in Toronto, Canada.
- And you're a Canadian citizen?
- No, well yeah I am now, yeah.
I've been here for 11 years.
- So look, I think the trickiest one
is deploying the patience and the balance
of paying for your life and debt off
while chasing a dream,
and the reality is that by
making the decisions you made
to collect debt for
something you didn't love,
that was in essence unfortunately,
it is for a lot of people,
ended up being a
"potentially wrong" decision,
which is okay.
There's nothing wrong with that.
What happens when that happens though
is it has to take longer, right?
It has to take longer.
- Yes.
- So the reality is back to your law,
it's not the law of attraction,
it's not like the cosmos all of a sudden
you know decided to put the down on you,
it's that you're putting
yourself in a position
for those things to happen
because you're thinking
about it more, right?
What happens now when
you've made a decision
that's a one step backwards,
now every minute has to be audited.
You know every minute has to be audited,
meaning you have to
put yourself in a place
where you're looking at
every minute you're spending
on the weekends and nights
and deploying that against behavior
that lets you get to your dream.
- I understand.
So also I wanted to ask
in terms of recommendation
like for being out there.
Should I get into TikTok
and Instagram as well?
- What do you think I'm gonna say?
- Well, you're gonna say yes,
but I mean like in terms of.
- Jowy, of course.
Like people get discovered.
Like all the kids that were
on Vine early and exploded
are acting in movies.
It already happened, Jowy,
it already happened.
It was called Vine.
- But the thing is for me,
I think I figured out my purpose,
and I know what I want to do with my life,
like acting is like my dream,
but what I want to do also is like
I want to do it for a purpose
which is to move people,
move people's hearts like
change their emotions.
- So make fucking content.
I'm changing people's
emotions and hearts right now.
It's free.
Just do it.
Stop talking about it, start doing it.
You got it.
- But like what kind of content?
- I don't know.
- That's the question.
- If you don't know how to fucking change
and move people's hearts,
then you're not gonna change
people's minds and hearts.
Like whatever the fuck you want,
like whatever you want to talk about.
Like changing people's minds and hearts
comes with ideas and the
ability to articulate that.
You can do that in the written word.
Hemingway fucking did that
in the written word, right?
Like you can do it in a
million different ways,
audio, video, you know written.
The ways to you know communicate
have been well established.
This is more getting out of
doubt and getting into clarity
and fucking executing.
- I understand.
- You know what I mean, Jowy,
like you just have to do.
You have to make.
There is no perfect.
This is about insecurity.
- I understand.
So you would recommend someone
to pay off their debts first
and then pursue their dream?
Or do both at the same time?
- Same time, parallel.
- Both.
- Don't do what you did
that put you in trouble.
When I heard you say
acting school or lessons,
people want to pay to be taught,
which actually means
they don't want to do.
You need acting fucking lessons,
fucking just act on TikTok.
Make skits.
- Okay.
- Don't pay somebody to make yourself feel
like you're doing it.
Do it.
I appreciate it, brother.
Guys let me wrap this up.
Thanks, Jowy.
Listen to everybody,
you know how many people
fucking pay for courses
to make themselves
believe they're doing it
when they're not doing it.
Just do, fucking make.
Fuck.
Great show.
ALL IN Challenge, please support it.
We're gonna end this with my auction.
And then of course I
didn't put in the plug yet.
If you haven't done
this yet, just fuck you.
If you haven't signed
up for fucking WineText,
honestly if you buy fucking wine
and you haven't signed up for WineText,
I'm gonna make it less confusing,
you know fuck you.
Like what are we doing out here.
Like why in the world would you buy wine
from somebody besides my dad?
That's some real shit,
especially when it's
the best fucking service
in the world on some real shit.
Fuck.
I'm just kidding, but I'm not.
Love you guys.
Jewel thanks for starting off the show.
Dustin you like that?
What, it was good, right?
- Just fuck you.
You didn't sign up, fuck you.
- I don't get it.
Like obviously I get it
if you're international.
Like I get it if you're in Illinois
or Texas or Utah and Michigan.
You can't buy from WineText
'cause we can't ship to every state,
but if you're in New York, New Jersey,
Pennsylvannia and you buy wine,
if you're in Florida and
Virginia and California,
like come on.
Like come on.
Like why would you buy
wine anywhere else, Dustin?
You get educated,
you get your palate expanded.
Today we have a fucking wine that's $22,
it's under $11, $10 and change.
It's the best fucking white,
like crazy white wine.
But I don't get it.
(Dustin chuckling)
I'm mad, I'm mad, I'm mad.
Like Donna Doherty better sign up.
I'm mad.
Like this 10 dollar and
70 something cents wine
we're gonna sell today,
is better than every $20 Sauvignon Blanc
or Sancerre or fucking
Riesling that people buy,
and like they're gonna
go to fucking Publix
or have the local liquor store deliver.
Like it makes no fucking sense to me.
Dustin?
Your parents drink wine?
- No, I brought them Empathy.
Like they had some of it,
but they don't drink wine that much.
- I respect that, I respect that.
- Yeah, if you don't drink wine it's good,
Dana we ship to Arizona.
Please go to winetext.com right now,
when we hang up.
Please? It would mean a lot to me.
Please sign up.
But come on.
All right.
And ALL IN Challenge, please donate to it.
Here's what I'm offering,
go buy a $10 raffle ticket,
and I can spend an entire year with you
doing all of this crazy shit.
(finger snapping)
I am giving away the
Ultimate GaryVee Experience.
How should that go?
Okay over the last week or so,
I've been jamming with
my friend Michael Rubin
and helping out on this ALL IN Challenge
that I am accepting right now.
But allinchallenge.com, please go there.
We are challenging some
of the greatest artists,
entertainers, athletes in the world
to provide a ridiculous
all-time experience
or one of their most iconic
items in their collection
to help raise money to
help feed the hungry
during this ridiculous time,
and so now I have to put up my auction.
So my auction,
the Ultimate GaryVee Experience,
here we go.
I'm gonna off the top of the head,
and you can go on allinchallenge.com
to go bid on this.
Okay, in the course of a year,
you will go garage selling
with me and film "Trash Talk."
Also you can get a workout
with me and Mike Vacanti,
so I know a lot of you pay attention
to that part of my world.
Also we're gonna go to Wine Library,
and do a $25,000 shopping spree.
That's right, I'm gonna pay my dad.
Well I'm gonna donate,
and we're gonna pay my dad $25,000,
so $25,000 shopping spree at Wine Library.
I will walk through the
whole store with you,
tell you the war stories,
and you'll buy a bunch
of wine, beer, liquor,
whatever you want, food.
We are going to go to
a Jets game together.
You're gonna tailgate with me.
I never do this when I
give away Jets tickets,
I never let the person sit with me,
so you will sit with me
during the Jets game.
I won't talk to you during the game.
I'm completely focused,
but you'll get that.
So the ultimate Jets experience,
tailgate, full game with me as well.
Also I'm going to give you
one week play at VaynerMedia.
So this is for you and
a plus one by the way,
so two tickets.
We'll do some plus ones,
we'll do some just me and you
depending on what it is.
One full week at VaynerMedia
getting consulting and business advice
from Team GaryVee and
me for the entire week,
hanging out in the pit
where the show's done.
You're gonna be a guest of my podcast.
We're going to do a wine dinner
for you and seven of your friends
at Hunt & Fish Club in New York City,
and I'm gonna fly you, all paid, plus one
to three of my keynotes,
and we'll work on those details.
The Ultimate GaryVee Experience.
I hope you bid on it.
I hope you get involved.
I hope we raise a lot of money
to help people that need it.
Also what's so fun about
the ALL IN Challenge
is you get to challenge
people to be in it.
I am gonna challenge all
the VaynerSports athletes.
I expect you in there,
so that is number one.
Number two, I'm gonna go with,
ooh, you know what?
Timbaland, the super producer,
who's completely lighting up Instagram.
I'm calling you out.
And finally, I got one, the Undertaker,
one of the great wrestlers of all time.
Please join the challenge.
Everybody go to allinchallenge.com.
Please support this.
The experiences are going to be nuts.
We've been working,
bleeding out of the eyeballs,
for the last week putting
this all together.
You're gonna be blown away
what you're about to see on social media,
#allinchallenge,
please check it out,
and please go to your favorite
celebrities, athletes and entertainers
and leave #allinchallenge
to get them involved.
The ALL IN Challenge,
please take it.